bière mediapart a publié une photo
d'alexandre apportons une arme alors
qu'il n'avait à l'époque pas de permis
de port d'armes est ce que ça jette le
trouble sur son édition de la semaine
dernière ce que vous allez le
reconvoquer coûté pour le moment nous
avons pris acte de ces faits comme nous
prenons acte tout les jours de faits
nouveaux
je peux vous dire que nous avons écrire
monsieur v là là pour lui demander un
certain nombre de précisions
ne portant pas sur ce sujet d'ailleurs
on avait écrit antérieurement suite à
son audition dont nous regardons les
choses nous prenons acte
nous constatons que avec le temps et
avec les auditions le champ des
contradictions s'accroît il y a de plus
en plus de questions qu'ils se posent
et cela va nourrir notre rapport dit
tout est possible mais ça relève de
notre décision et tout est possible